el humo se eleva desde la torre de
televisión de kiev sin embargo horas
después del ataque la mayoría de los
canales ucranianos volvieron a funcionar
con normalidad pero las fuerzas rusas
atacaron también una central eléctrica y
el principal monumento conmemorativo del
holocusto en la capital de ucrania de
qué sirve decir nunca más durante 80
años si el mundo se queda callado cuando
cae una bomba en el mismo lugar de
familiar al menos 5 muertos la historia
se repite el ejército ruso que según
imágenes satelitales está cada vez más
cerca de kiev pidió a los civiles que se
mantengan alejados de las instalaciones
de los servicios de seguridad
entretanto harkov la segunda ciudad más
grande de ucrania fue nuevamente
bombardeada tras días de intensos
combates las fuerzas rusas atacaron el
principal edificio administrativo en la
plaza central de la ciudad mientras que
en el sur del país las tropas rusas
cercan también las localidades de gerson
y mariupol que fueron también
intensamente bombardeadas según sus
gobernadores en el sexto día de guerra
ofensiva estaría lidiando con escasez de
comida y combustible mientras ucrania
está en alerta máxima